let's go back to the phones by which I
mean Discord we take calls on Fridays at
davidpackman.com
Discord we are going to go next to
Julian in New York City Julian what's
going on
hey David I just um well a couple weeks
ago I heard your interview with Anand
girdardas and the the persuaders book
which I Anand
yeah I guess the emphasis is at the
beginning yeah I got I got it one and
two off the air with him Anand Anand
Anand yes Anand wonderful I mean
fantastic
fantastic interview I think really I
thought you know one of your best in the
past year but I read his book The
persuaders and one of my favorite
sections was
um Democratic messaging or about
Democratic messaging with the recent um
wins in the Senate you know the
expanding the majority all that yep what
do we how do we
um keep pushing Democrats and I guess
larger Progressive communities to to
keep because you know the messaging is
an issue it's still an issue yeah we won
but we we still have this huge problem
that is sort of like a I don't know it's
like a virus that doesn't seem to you
know I guess my question is where is
gonna how do we build this incentive to
keep pushing our community in the right
direction well listen when you say the
messaging are you talking about about
messaging from elected Democrats or from
people ancillary to the Democratic party
like Progressive activists or who what
messaging exactly are you referring to I
starts at the top and then Works its way
down I mean it can start you know
anywhere from Bernie and then
and then kind of flows down it's this
it's this uh framing things
conceding these crazy
um made up points that Republicans say
about either the Border or whatever well
give me an example of that so like
whether it's Bernie or whatever what's
what's a point that the left has
conceded On the Border
like Republicans will say okay they're
they're you know so many
um illegal immigrants are crossing the
border and then Democrats will say we're
gonna we're gonna
be just as strong On the Border but
we're also going to make sure that new
jobs and and stuff is being so you know
like in uh uh encountering that point
they're not they're not um they're
conceding that they're that they too we
too want to be strong at the border and
I guess I mean I think that's an example
because there's an opera so there's two
different issues here it's the the
reason why it's really hard to say
here's the way to frame this and I'm not
a framing guy you need the truth is you
need to figure out what would actually
be effective here there's like three
different issues at the border that are
from a rhetoric standpoint and a
propaganda standpoint one is the story
that the day Trump left and Biden took
over something dramatically changed at
the border that now allows a free flow
of undocumented immigrants over the
border that that didn't happen right so
that like that's one issue that you have
to deal with number two is the issue of
it is because of Republicans getting in
the way that significant immigration
reform hasn't been done a lot of
low-hanging fruit could have been dealt
with DACA could have been dealt with
with a path to to citizenship for those
who came here when they weren't even
adults they were just brought here by
parents it's Republicans who have gotten
in the way of that to some degree
because they they see oh we don't want
to give Democrats that Victory or
whatever the case may be so there
there's that issue as well and then
number three
there's the Republican
I don't know what to call it but it's oh
there's an election coming up well then
we should talk about Caravans and then
all of a sudden the day after the
election we don't mention Caravans
anymore and there's an auction coming up
we got to talk about violent crime by
undocumented immigrants the day after
the election they don't talk about it
anymore so there's that Brazen
um uh hypocrisy when it comes to when
they even claim to care it's a lot to
deal with I don't have the right
messaging on it I don't know
yes yeah and I guess to sort of surmise
what I'm what I'm trying to say is it
feels like we're always playing catch-up
with the messaging they say something
they State something it could be
blatantly false and then we don't even
you know disprove it we just go with it
at and yes and rather than um really
putting our foot down and so with the
recent wins that I just I just want to
make sure that we keep a pressure on I
agree with you I just don't know who it
is that is well positioned like maybe
it's Anand I don't know to give some
advice about what should the language be
around some of these issues to fight the
Republican framing which is so dishonest
and inaccurate absolutely yeah well
thanks very much David my pleasure all
right great to uh great to hear from
Julian in New York City why don't we go
next to oh I don't know how about uh
Rose calling from the United States God
bless the United States Rose welcome to
the program
hey David
um I owe you an apology for
love that sounds great let's start there
what what did you do wrong
um I interrupted you but while you're
talking I have ADHD and sometimes I I do
that
um all right we're talking about space
uh so
um here's uh here's my point like I've
been feeling more and more that we're
hurtling towards the future that most of
us aren't even prepared for uh let alone
dreaming dreaming about so
um
are you aware about like the uh General
risk profiler on nuclear proliferation
yeah in fact I recently read the book
precipice by Toby ORD wherein he talks
about existential risks to Homo sapiens
and devotes quite a bit of time uh to to
sort of a nuclear
um I don't know what you would even call
it a nuclear Holocaust for lack of a
better term yes so to some degree I've
read about it yes
so
um there's been back in the 1960s there
was this project called the nits country
project
um where they gave to a grad students
one of them left and so it was in three
three grad students in total
um recently graduated almost no
experience
a library and access to basic technical
help and basic calculations uh this was
1960 so that meant computer time
and ask them to come up with a working
schematics for an implosion style device
this was like the at the bomb Houston
Nagasaki the fat boy it's like a sphere
of plutonium and explosives explosive
lenses around it and the explosion goes
off in like precise nanosecond timing
yeah and it like compresses the sphere
into a tiny ball and causes fission and
then boom they managed to create a
working model from scratch
in two and a half years the creative
working schematic from two and a half
years it was meant to see if how long
would it take a nation state to do this
the end of the country at a time only
the US and the USSR could do it
uh most of the information needed to
build a weapon like this has always been
open source it's like 80 year old
technology but the constraint has always
been the materials
but now it feels like it's getting
easier and easier and easier to do it I
was playing with chat GPT yes and I
managed to get it to do certain things
um
including
um automatically generates a certain
things related to uh this technology uh
one might say that it would have
ordinarily taken me
um uh weeks of research to do and it
didn't I'm not sure I know what you're
saying and I'm not sure if there's a
question are you saying that you were in
a conversation with this chat bot chat
GPT you were able to get information
from it which presumably it sourced from
available information about how to build
a nuclear device is that what you're
saying
it's it's synthesized that it took what
it would have been like weeks of
synthesis and did it in 10 seconds
understood and then it kind of like spat
out information about how such a such a
device might be built yeah the
dimensions are different parts and so on
like how to calculate the dimensions and
record for it and so
um and how to simulate it
um I I feel like a lot of the
conversation that I've had with
conservatives and so on and in the
future that they imagine
um it is really disconnected with the
future that we we have and the future
that I'm seeing coming like when I saw
that it actually really shocked me so I
I had this moment of Future Shock you
know like I wish my mom I get it Rose
did did you have a question today
yes it what do you feel about this is
there a way to bridge that disconnect is
this is there a which disconnect are you
referring to
uh but
ton way to them that hey the
fighting over
not exactly the most prosaic of issues
no I don't I don't have any insights as
to how one might do that I mean we all
there's I've talked before this idea
where you know if we made first contact
with an intelligent alien species all of
a sudden we would all realize that our
Earthly problems are really quite
meaningless in the grand scheme of
things and finding other intelligent
life and War would end and then you know
I've spoken to enough scientists who say
yeah that wouldn't really happen it
would sort of maybe temporarily do that
and then things would go back to the
exact same uh debates and disagreements
that we have and and people can't uh
sort of more permanently um uh be uh in
in that mindset so I don't have any
great insights as to as to how to
connect people with the potential future
we're hurtling towards I wish I did
thank you so much and I shall read the
book Thank you all right there is Rose
very very important message and making a
lot of different claims I would say